أثارت مظاهرة أخيرة قامت بها مجموعة من
النساء رد فعل عنيف
أدى إلى تعليق بعضهن
عن وظائفهن.
المدينة
للمطالبة برحلة تعتبر أمرًا مفروغًا منه في
جميع أنحاء العالم ولكنها محظورة هنا ليس
بموجب القانون ولا بموجب القرآن بل من خلال
هذه الثقافة الإسلامية المحافظة ، لذلك
يتم قيادة النساء هنا من قبل
أفراد الأسرة الذكور أو السائقين حتى أولئك
الذين قد يقودون سيارات إسلامية أخرى  مجتمعات
مثل الكويت ، على سبيل المثال ، أحب
القيادة ، وأتمنى أن أتمكن من القيادة في
بلدنا في بلدنا ، ستسمع
نفس الشيء من جميع
النساء السعوديات المتعلمات والمهنيات تقريبًا ، لكن حتى
معظم الليبراليين يقولون إن المتظاهرين استخدموا
التكتيكات الخاطئة التي ينبغي للتغيير  تعال من
خلال الحوار لا المظاهرة